Customer wants to buy something,
company wants to sell something,
what's sitting in between them?
A form.
If you think about registration,
a company wants to grow their user base,
someone wants to be part of that
community, or product or they have.
And again what's between them is a form.
So in all these places where
this connection happens
between the organizations that
make things on the internet, and
the people that use those things,
there's generally a form.
And those forms as you say
consist of input fields.
The biggest mistake that i think people
make is treating those things from
what I would call almost
a back end perspective.
That is inside of a database,
to simplify things, you have these name
value pairs, right, name and
then a field for what the name is.
And you've got a whole
bunch of these things and
they constitute something like
the record of a user, or a purchase.
And when it comes time to collect
that information to fully fill in
that database, what you do is you just
spit out those name value pairs as input
fields and labels.
And ta-da, job done with a form.
So both of these things I learned
almost the hard way, if you will,
at eBay about how to think
about them differently.
When I was at Ebay many years ago it was
the 28th largest economy in the world.
So lots and lots of people buying and
selling things on there.
And we found that when we made small
changes to these forms we could really
have a huge impact.
In fact when we redesigned
the registration form process,
we had to go back to Wall Street and
restate earnings because that was
how tremendous the impact was.
And when you think about the ability for
something like a form to impact
something like the 28th largest economy
in the entire planet, you really start
to understand the importance of all
the little details in the forms.
And that goes well beyond which
name value pairs you include.
How you put the labels in,
what kind of form control you use,
what kind of feedback you give to people
as they're filling in this information.
How do you organize it?
What do you do to message the before and
after parts of the form?
because it's a part of a broader flow.
And so the biggest mistake is really not
considering that full envelope of form
design, and really just regurgitating
a database's fields onto a screen and
putting a submit button on the bottom